voie de liaison rapide par excellence
l'autoroute doit avoir un tracé simple
et nec a procédé de conception française
permet d'éviter toute erreur dans ce
domaine les éléments chiffrés relevés
sur le terrain sont d'abord collationner
et transcrit à l'aide d'une machine
appelée coordinateur graff sous la forme
de cartes perforées toutes les coptes du
profil sont ensuite confrontés avec le
plan d'étude de l'autoroute
c'est le travail d'un ordinateur
électroniques dont les conclusions
enregistré sur bande magnétique sont
reproduites d'une façon concrète et
intelligible par une machine à dessiner
rapide et infaillible cet appareillage
peut traduire en moins de 30 minutes le
profil en long d'un kilomètre
d'autoroute
ainsi pour cette voie ferrée que doit
longer une autoroute urbaine deux
possibilités s'offraient la
superposition ou bien la version rail
route au même niveau dont les dessins
ont été réalisées automatiquement en
concrétisant rapidement les plans des
tubes
cette méthode permet d'éviter certaines
erreurs auparavant ils évitent ainsi les
perspectives successifs d'une portion
d'autoroute font apparaître un
infléchissement à gauche à la fois
dangereuse inutile déplacé vers la
droite d'une centaine de mètres et
soumis à l'appréciation de l'ordinateur
le nouveau projet se traduit par une
courbe logique et une visibilité
parfaite
l'important passage autoroutier couvert
de 12 100 m qui reliera le pont de
neuilly au rond-point de la défense
posait dans chaque sens d'épineux
problèmes d'aiguillage grâce au dessin
automatique on peut imaginer ce que vera
l'automobiliste qui se rendra de
levallois à bougival entrée à droite
il appuiera à gauche une première fois
la signalisation semble bonne et à
bonchamp corps en direction de reuil et
de la nationale traite ainsi grâce à
l'électronique
vous êtes les premiers à emprunter le
futur passage couvert de la défense